polygon or matic a cryptocurrency
established in india was created to make
ethereum blockchain transactions faster
and cheaper
polygon has attracted a large number of
customers due to its possible
applications
it is currently ranked among the top 20
cryptocurrencies in terms of market
capitalization
so let's take a look at all you need to
know about it before you buy it
hey everyone i'm sharmly and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on matic crypto
in this video i will take you through
various important concepts and
components of thematic
first we will explore what is polygon
followed by what is matic
then we will look into the features of
matec and after that we will understand
how does polygon works
then we will discover why is it
important to ethereum
and what is its current value and
circulating supply
and at last we will discuss is it a good
investment or not so without further ado
let's get started with the video
so let's start with what is polygon
polygon formerly known as matic network
is a scaling solution that seeks to give
several methods to boost the speed of
transactions on blockchain networks
while also lowering the cost and
complexity
polygon describes itself as a layer 2
network which means it is an add-on
layer to ethereum that does not attempt
to alter the original blockchain layer
like its geometric namesake it has
numerous sides shapes and applications
and it promises to be a more
straightforward framework for creating
interconnected networks
polygon is a scaling solution that seeks
to give several methods to boost the
speed of transactions on blockchain
network while also lowering their cost
and complexity
now that brings us to what is matic
after the rebranding polygon retained
its massive cryptocurrency the digital
coin underpinning the network
matic is the payment and settlement unit
for participants who engage within the
network and is also utilized to keep
tokens safe on the polygon network
since then it has received an incredible
cost surge following a tremendous
expansion in use
the matic cryptocurrency is available on
a number of well-known decentralized and
centralized trading platforms including
binance one in exchange and coinbase pro
the crypto community is banding together
to make it easier to buy polygon or
matic tokens by making them available in
both fiat and crypto
so now that we know what they are let's
have a look at the features of matic
first is it provides blockchain
performance enhancement technologies
polygon sidechain was one of the first
things they offered a sidechain is a
blockchain that links to it and improves
its performance
transactions are processed faster and
fees are significantly lower
second is its goal to create foundation
of blockchain network
polygon's future goals are huge its
purpose is to create a foundation full
of blockchain networks
instead of being completely disconnected
users would be able to establish
blockchain networks that interconnect
third comes its ethereum virtual machine
or evm compatible
because polygon is evm compatible
developers can easily port their apps to
it
avei and sushi swap are just two of the
popular ethereum apps that have already
been deployed on polygon
then comes other blockchain networks as
well as ethereum 2.0
could provide challenges polygon isn't
the only blockchain network initiative
in the works
others such as polkadot and avalanche
provide interconnected blockchains
projects like these may co-exist or one
may develop a superior solution and
abandon the others ethereum has also
been releasing updates to ethereum 2.0
in a series of releases
and next is fees governance and staking
are all handled through the polygon
token we have discussed the project's
objectives but what about polygons
cryptocurrency token it can be utilized
in a variety of ways
now we have almost covered the basic
let's type down and understand how it
works
polygon is a multi-level platform that
intends to grow ethereum by using a
variety of side chains to unlock the
main platform in a cost effective and
efficient manner
if you're not aware of side chains there
are separate blockchains that are linked
to the main ethereum blockchain and can
support a variety of decentralized
finance protocols
as a result polygon can be linked to
networks like polka dot cosmos and
avalanche
now let's have a look at why is it
important ethereum
matic is compatible with the evm
developers that are accustomed to
working with ethereum can easily
transition to polygon polygon has a
security layer that may be turned on or
off which enable enables
sovereign platforms to forego additional
protection while maintaining their
freedom
and
flexibility
matic tokens can be used to vote on
polygon improvement proposals and
participate in network governance
so now let's have a look at the crypto
market value of matic
according to market cap polygon's
current price is 1.30
usd dollars
and the maximum supply of polygon is 10
billion out of which till today its
supply has reached 6.67 billion
now the question comes is it a good
investment
so if you're thinking about investing in
matic keep in mind that cryptocurrencies
are quite volatile so you need to be
prepared for large price things
so only invest money you can afford to
lose and make sure to build up your
emergency savings and retirement account
first however investors should keep an
eye on the implementation of ethereum
too
as well as the activity of polygons
competitors
there's still a lot to play for in this
sector and it's unclear how it will
develop well this was all about matic
so what are your thoughts on matic
and will you be investing money in it
we have almost reached the end of this
video if i missed anything important do
let me know in the comment section
i hope you enjoyed this video on matic
and learn something new from it if you
liked this video then please hit the
like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates and videos from
simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here